In the last section, I talked
a bit about the apply family
of functions.
These are very powerful
functions for applying the
same function across
many sets of data.
They're even more powerful when
combined with custom functions.
To begin, I'm going to create
a sample object x that's a
matrix with 1,000 rows and 10
columns containing 10,000
random draws from a Poisson
distribution with
8 degrees of freedom.
If you recall, I could use
apply to apply a function
across each row or column.
Here I've calculated the
mean for each column.
If I wanted, I could also create
a custom function on
the fly that calculates the
standard error of the mean
using each column separately.
Note that here I've omitted the
braces for the function
declaration.
I did this since the function
can fit on one line, but I
could include braces
if I liked.
This in line use of functions is
very useful since it allows
you to apply simple custom
functions on the fly.
It's also common to make complex
functions and use them
in the third argument
of apply.
Here I'm going to first load
in the getCI function, then
I'm going to call it
inside of apply.
You might recall that the
getCI function actually
returned a list.
The apply function adapts its
output to accommodate complex
outputs by the function
being applied.
Sometimes it will return a
vector, other times a matrix,
and other times a list.
Here, since getCI outputs
a list, the best way to
represent many outputs of that
function is to contain them in
a sort of super list.
This completes the fourth
section of videos.
Take some time to try out what
you've learned in these first
four sections of video, browse
online for some data, or
access some of these data sets
that are already present in
your R session.